Hello, nice to meet you. Uh my name is
Chong.
Uh I am right now CTO and co-founder of
Sunday Robotics.
Uh and I have a little few slides about
myself.
Um so, you know, I started as an
undergrad in University of Michigan.
That's the first time I, you know, set
foot in the United States.
Uh and I'm very fortunate to be advised
by Dimitri Berenson for my undergrad.
That's the first time I had research
experience
uh and you know, understand what it's
like for academia.
Um
and then after that, I did my PhD uh
with uh my lovely uh advisor Peter Allen
uh we started out in Columbia University
in uh New York City. And then I moved
with her to Stanford uh towards the end
of my PhD.
Uh
and so, you know, during my PhD, there
are two works that I really enjoyed
working on. One is called diffusion
policy uh or you I think told me that
you guys might have covered similar
material. Uh you know, there's a lot of
works similar to diffusion policy now.
Uh for example, I think there's people
using flow matching, people use
diffusion for, you know, video and
action generation, people use diffusion
for uh you know, like for uh locomotion.
Uh turns out to be uh used by quite a
few people.
Uh and then uh my last work at uh
during my PhD was called universal
manipulation interface.
Uh I would say this is much more uh
hardware project than a software
project. Uh really and the code base is
the same as the diffusion policy. But uh
you know, the project the the work's
about this kind of open-source
lightweight uh gripper that allows you
to collect data without needing a robot.
And I would say uh my my life after PhD
is much more about scaling this uh
universal manipulation interface project
than uh scaling the diffusion policy
project.
Uh and yeah, right now also after do
after my PhD, I actually I met uh Tony
initially at Twitter after uh the uh
diffusion policy announcement.
Uh and then and then again, we got
reunited at Stanford uh because Tony was
also at Stanford. Uh and then we started
this company called uh Sunday Robotics.
Uh today, I'm going to talk about uh
like this lecture is called uh robotics
beyond algorithms uh where I'll talk a
lot about a lot of aspects that I
learned after my PhD graduation. A lot
of them are quite surprising to me uh
and it'll be less so about, you know,
generative modeling or traditional what
I learned uh during my during my
my student times. Uh but I wish I I knew
uh before coming to the startup.
Yeah, what would look like uh look at a
modern robotics company and robot
robotic system, uh by modern I mean, you
know, after I graduate my PhD, uh pretty
much everybody everything is focused
around the policy.
for different companies, uh it might be
different uh so, from manipulation
company will be
uh you know, like a visual motor policy
uh or in academia as well. And then for
works that relate to locomotion, there's
often like a blind uh RL policy.
Uh and then uh still, you know, we are
even though people keep saying about
end-to-end, there was there was never
actually end-to-end. Uh there's always
some software uh between uh the sensor
uh and the uh and the policy and the
actuators.
Uh so, like there's a layer of robotic
software often uses various kind of
classical robotic algorithms uh from the
simplest to like PID control uh to
something more complicated like SLAM.
Uh and then I would say uh these two
areas are usually what I like
during my undergrad during my PhD, these
are what I what I understand that these
are called robotics. And fundamentally,
these are really a robotic algorithms.
Uh
I I think they're very popular because
I'm in a CS department and these
algorithms are they're very fun, they're
very interesting uh and they're also
very easy to teach because
fundamentally, if you implement them,
it's just software. Uh so, you just uh
clone clone a repo and run some scripts.
Uh it's very easy to design homeworks
around. Um but after uh
Oh, okay. Yeah, so like, you know, these
are how I learned during uh
uh for robotics about these aspects. Uh
so, I learned these uh during classes.
Um so, these are two of my uh uh
favorite
uh classes, modern robotics by Kevin
Lynch and interactive robotics by uh
Peter Ross Hendrick.
Um these are, you know,
when when I was in during my in uh in my
undergrad and early days of PhD, I took
all these classes and tell I taught me
about math, theory, and algorithms about
robotics.
Uh and then during my PhD,
uh uh robot robot learning became very
popular and then I I start reading
papers and these are how I learned about
robot learning.
Um but I would say uh after graduation,
I realized that these are only actually
a small part of robotics and there's
like many other things uh especially
hardware and data that's I would say
very very critical to get robotic system
work. And I would say it's actually a a
very big differentiator between
different works or between different
teams.
Uh so, first I want to talk about
hardware.
Uh and I want to use an example of like
building a very simple component, you
know, everybody pretty much everybody
know uh needs to use at some point if
you want to do robotics. Uh it's a
camera.
Uh so, you know, if I want to build a
camera, uh like when I started a
project, uh it will be like a kind of
there's an analogy uh to when you're
starting a software project. So, uh in
software, you're probably let's say you
don't want to work on some generative
model uh
project, then you go uh Google search uh
some uh repositories that you're
interested uh you download the
repository. And for hardware, really
it's, you know, rarely you want to start
fully from scratch. Uh so, what you do
is that uh you either find open-source
hardware out there or you go on Amazon,
buy something similar and you take it
apart and see how it's made up.
Um and often a very important step uh
during this process to find reusable
components.
For example, uh you know,
for the software project, uh also also
often find a file called requirement.txt
or it's called something
something.conda.yaml file and you'll see
a lot of dependencies. So, you install
numpy packages, pytorch, opencv. These
are almost, you know, uh
like in every single project. Uh and in
the in the camera hardware example, we
see that there's important components.
There's a lens, uh there's a sensor,
there's ISP. You know, these are have
system models and then we know that if
you want to build a build a like a
camera like this, you need these
components.
And in the software land, uh so, like
when when you put all these components
together, uh you know, in the software
land, we call this you know, what I call
requirement.txt. Really this is a it's a
build instruction uh or it's uh it's
like a software dependency list. Uh in
hardware, the corresponding concept is
called BOM, bill of materials. So, on
the right, I have a screenshot uh for
part of the diffusion policy project. It
really is like what are the parts you
need to buy, what the quantity, the link
to buy, and how much does it cost.
Uh and you know, once you have this uh
the this uh like this list, uh you need
to build your development environment.
Uh so, in a software project, what I do
is that you pip install.
Uh and so, really that that is
automatically fetches all the packages
uh to your local environment so you can
start finally start writing code. And in
hardware, this is actually much more
complicated uh because, you know, these
components might come from different
vendors. Uh like the easy thing is you
can buy on Amazon, but sometimes, you
know, things are out of stock. Uh so,
like this is really it's called this
process called procurement. Um you know,
this is like you really really bare-bone
prerequisite before you start any
hardware project.
And I would say, you know, this is kind
of like how things end at at least for
me uh when uh for UMI. Uh the reason uh
is that and then everything is every
working quite smoothly uh because all of
my uh material bill of materials are on
Amazon. So, uh it it is something called
a retail channel. Uh that's that's
something you can you can just, you
know, quickly can buy. And really it
it's retail, I think it's pretty
powerful abstraction. It creates an
illusion of low latency. So, you can get
exactly what what you want very quickly.
And the reason what you and the entire
business of retail is this building this
cash and physical caching layer. So, at
where uh you know, the customers are,
you have these shelves and or virtual
shelves where you put stuff on. Uh and
then uh and then when people want it,
they just grab it from from this local
cash.
But really this is an illusion of how
the physical world actually works.
Um
if you want to change anything about
any of these components or if you want
to order large quantity at a time, uh
you either quickly exhaust these cash uh
in in the retail channels or you will
need to make your
your supplier or your supplier's
suppliers change something. Uh so,
camera module is made of lens, PCB, and
cable. Each of component have their own
supplier. So, you know, like lens uh
supplier buy glasses, buy housing. PCB
supplier get like a design file for you
and then like buy sensor, buy ISP, put
it together. Really just everybody is in
the business of buying stuff and putting
things together and selling it.
And this is what what we call supply
chain.
Uh and I I I think it's more appropriate
to call it a supply tree.
And you know, like as things go forward,
uh
the timeline like as like it's actually
as like, you know, the more complex uh
the product you work on, the timeline
complexity blows up really really
quickly. Uh so, imagine that if nobody's
like everybody's operating on this like
Amazon model like model where you talk
to your supplier, uh you know, they buy
uh 10 lenses and then they realize
they're all stuck for the lenses that
work for the glasses. Uh and then they
need to go to their supplier and then
supplier need to
like into now okay, realize okay, now
I'm out of stock, need to buy all those
things. Uh it's going to take like many
many months for a complex product to
complete.
Uh and and that's why
uh you need something called supply
chain management. Uh you know, this is
really like a really important job, a
full-time job. A person to not only talk
to your supplier, but your supplier's
supplier, supplier's supplier, and then
to inform them, "Okay, all I need is new
part or I need this new product, and I
need a lot of them." So, you you give
all of them heads-up so that they can
start ramping up all their production,
uh and then they're all uh in sync in
terms of schedule such that eventually
you can get the part you want at
quality. Uh so, to me, I think analogy
is kind of like a UV. Uh instead of
where pip you only fetch the the first
layer of dependencies, you look at all
of our dependency tree and make sure
everything's uh consistent.
Uh and the reason I spend so much time
talking about supply chain is really
this is something I learned the most
about hardware. Is that uh supply chain
uh for hardware sometimes either equally
important or even more important because
it dictates uh whether you can make a
buy versus build decision. This is very
similar decision if you're building
hardware software as well. So, let's
Can you hear me?
Hello. Any question? No, no, all good,
all good. We're good. All good. All
right, all right. Cool.
Yeah, so this is about buy and build
decision. Uh
so, if you know, if if you if you have a
good supply chain management, then you
really can optimize what you need to
build or what what what what you need to
buy. Uh and a common mistake I see uh
you know,
researchers going to hardware is that
they try to build everything themselves,
whereas many things are available out
there.
Uh and then now let's say we have all
the parts. Now we need to actually build
the glove. And then all right, this is
uh this is what we call skill capture
glove. It's you know, our data
collection. Uh so, it's derived from
UMi. Uh and then this is the 1,000th
glove we made. We painted it gold.
Uh and really uh the first step you need
to do is assembly.
Uh so, you know, you take all these part
all these parts, you put them together
manually. Uh for UMi, I have a video
tells teach you how to do that. And then
here, really you need something called
standard operating procedure or SOP. Uh
and then uh here like this is our uh a
lovely technician, Chris. And then here
is a piece of paper in front of him. Uh
this is part of our SOP. And there's
in practice many many uh like many many
pages, and then it's divided across
different work stations.
And like what you usually see is our
business build something. Uh you know,
if you try to build anything really, uh
you will quickly realize you have some
issue. Uh often is about uh consistency.
So, if you want to measure anything, you
build camera or you build like a angle
sensor, uh like you you measure some
some reading, and then by build putting
things together, things are almost never
consistent uh across different units.
And so, the first thing to solve that
problem is to first you need to be
identify uh each glove or each uh each
product you built. Uh so, here uh you
know, we print a label that have like a
QR code for a serial number of of this
thing. Uh and then inside database, we
actually track uh all of the components.
And then once you can identify uh a
glove from another, uh the next step we
do is calibration and QA. So, this these
are also done together uh in software.
So, here we really just plug in uh the
glove into computer, you perform a bunch
of actions, and that records how like
the the min and max range uh of of of
each joint on the glove. Uh and then uh
use that, you can you can calibrate you
know, like the reading of the sensor.
And also you can use this as QA. So,
let's say you're moving the finger, but
the reading on the computer is not
moving, you know something's wrong. Uh
or even the calibration range is super
off compared to other gloves, then you
know that something some some mistake
has been made. Uh then you need to uh
either go send the glove back to our
manufacturing or you need to reject it.
And again, like when I when I talk about
these things, it sounds very simple, but
when you're making, you know, hundreds
of gloves, thousands of gloves, that
should become a very very challenging
task. You know, like when when human is
doing any kind of work, you make
mistakes. And then, you know, I I can I
can see if you build thousands thousands
of them, the probability of mistake is
extremely high. Um
And really here I think uh like like
Henry is our founding software engineer.
He built a critical tool
uh which is called this is really
to track all the data about glove uh in
the in the software system.
Uh and then and then there's a step
after that where uh pack and ship. So,
you print a shipping label, you put
everything in a box, and then you ship
it out.
So, this entire process is called FATP.
It's called final assembly, test, and
pack up. And this is probably like when
you hear about manufacturing, this
company called called Foxconn, uh you
know, things like that, they do this
kind of work for Apple. Uh these are
really when people think about factory,
this is what's happening in the factory.
It's called FATP.
And I really I think like for for uh for
this aspect, uh the the biggest thing I
learned is the power of software.
Um so, you know, when you when you're
building very complex hardware, there's
a lot of moving parts. There's a lot of
people involved. There are there's a lot
of components. And in our case, the
quality of this hardware we build
directly impacts the quality of data
that that we can get. And therefore, it
is very very critical for us to be able
to like have a visibility to every
aspect of of this process.
Uh and that's why, you know, uh we we we
uh Henry built like actually he he he
proposed to build a software for us uh
like because he you know, he
really he go to the uh
eats dinner on the same table with
people who put the glove together and
then buy all the parts. And he also goes
to gym together with them. He really is
in constant collaboration uh with people
actually doing the work. So, he he
quickly realized that there's a huge
bottleneck uh that's like slowing down
our production is just that people that
the information are scattered around.
People need to install these like random
Python scripts here and there, and that
really uh drives down efficiency. Uh so,
what we found that what
in the end we were able to do is uh
through the software, we're able to
track every single component uh at of
the glove and who built the glove, when
when was the glove built, how was the
glove calibrated, and then we can track
it to every single piece of data that we
collect. Uh and then so, eventually and
this this information is available all
the way to our training data loader.
Therefore, researcher, if they think
something sucks about a specific kind of
glove, uh they can just change change a
uh data loading config, and that will
all be handled.
So, we found that this is actually very
critical and uh in the end a very
impactful work. Um
I think the my takeaway here uh is just
that uh many times uh there exists a
software solution for a hardware problem
and vice versa. And often that like this
the solution and the problem space may
not exist in the same in the same
domain.
And that's why we need people who
understand the entire cycle or like who
understand multiple aspects to find
optimal solution.
Yeah. So, the next aspect we'll talk
about is data collection. You know, this
will go less in depth, uh but I really
want to tell a few stories.
Uh so, you know, when we started uh
really so I I during my PhD as uh
reading the about researchers collecting
data. So, these are my my co-author, uh
Shu and Jinjia uh from both from
Curran's lab. Uh so, we we take this UMi
gripper, we go everywhere around
Stanford or in the area, we collect
data, and then train the model. Um and
this is like I would say the easiest
mode data collection because uh you
know, everybody is researcher. Everybody
can understand what it takes to train a
model, and everybody understands like uh
have good intuition about how they
collect data. The data the quality of
data directly impacts the uh the the end
policy you want.
Uh but uh things get a lot more
complicated when you need to scale data
collection operation.
Uh so, at Sunday, we have three
generations of data collection owner. Uh
so, the first uh owner was as my
co-founder, Tony. Uh he started out as a
PhD student at uh at Stanford, and he's
now CEO of company. He started out as
CEO of company. Uh and he really go
like, you know, hand hand hand in hand
hand by hand like, you know, recruited
the first 20 member developers. Uh these
like are terminology for data collection
uh data collector.
And so, uh it's it's about, you know,
knocking on doors, about posting uh
random posts on Craigslist, trying to
find uh
like people to apply.
And then after that, uh Camilla take
over. Uh Camilla, she already started uh
originally started as a campaign manager
like for a political campaign in local
uh
mayor for for Honolulu uh in Hawaii. And
then she uh become our head of
operations and took over the data
operations from Tony. And then she
really scaled our data collection
operation from 20 people to 200 people.
Uh and during this process, uh you know,
we need to find we need to like things
completely changed. We need to have a
formalized process of recruiting,
formalized process of qualification, and
then, you know, like a streamlined
process of shipping uh items out. Um but
at this layer, uh she still
can directly interact and understand
like every every person who collect
data.
Uh but eventually we uh like we realized
that that model uh cannot scale beyond
this number. This is like for one
person, this is about as much people you
can keep a relationship as possible.
So, Perry is our our our our right now
current owner of our uh of our data. So,
he actually started out as a data
labeler at Tesla uh for Tesla autopilot.
And then he grew all the way to leading
all of the data labeling operation
inside Tesla. Uh and then now he's our
head of data. And he's really growing
from this 200 people that Camilla left,
and now to thousands of people that
collect data for us every day.
Um and one thing I really learned the
most
about uh about data operations is that
uh so, when when when I started out,
you know, I'm I'm a technical person.
So, I uh I want to I I want to write
good code, write good user interface. I
also maybe there's some like AI
generated instruction that can help
people collect data more. But what I
really
learned is that uh data
data collection is an operation. And
operations is really all the way about
people. So if you if you understand
people and you can build a good
communication, you can build good trust,
then really you don't need much fancy
software. Just a Slack channel
and then some spreadsheet will be good
enough for like
let's say a 200 people.
Uh but you know if you if you don't get
the people part right, people don't feel
like they're they're valued, they're
respected, and they don't they don't
clearly understand exactly what you need
and exactly what you don't want, then
actually there's no amount of software,
there's no amount of technical work that
you can you can fix that hole.
Uh
and one thing we found really cool is
that you know once people are really
motivated, they understand like they
they really want to contribute to
actually make the home robot reality, uh
people started going all the way to help
us. So when we started at Sunday,
actually in the beginning we're doing
some kind of like Android phone-based
tracking solution and then it was like
really not robust against white walls.
So one of our memory memory developer,
he invented this method, he put sticky
notes on the on the wall by trial by
trial and error and realized that these
can add features to the wall and can
really help stabilize the system.
And like really just like you know being
able to fully engage with the community
of memory memory developers really
really help us early on when we started
when when the technology technology is
not not mature.
Yeah, so in the end data is about
people. As like there's something about
technology, but people is the most
important aspect.
Uh
I would say like the reason I I put put
together these slides is that you know
in my in my
the way I I grew up and the way I
learned robotics is that like my my my
my vision about robotics all about
algorithm. It's how can I make the
algorithms better, how we get you know
different paradigm of learning different
paradigm of data that that is able to
you know make robot from not working to
working, which I think is very
important. But I will also say that the
world is actually quite big compared to
academia. There's many in order to make
something work actually work in the
you know in the real world to build an
actual product that some people I
actually use. Uh there's a long way to
go
and a lot to learn beyond just what what
I learned in academia to what I actually
what what I need to do on a daily basis.
And and that's what I think is like very
very fun, very interesting. And I wish I
knew these things before I started the
company and like I wish that there's a
lecture
during my undergrad that teach me all
these things.
And that's what I'm doing right now.
And really during this process,
even half this idea during my PhD is
that I think being able to operate
operate across a stack is really really
important. Uh so in academia our
education system is usually often
structured in a way that's like a
vertically divided. So you know you are
a mechanical engineer student. You are a
software like computer science PhD
student. You're an electrical engineer
PhD student. Or
in robotics you have you are slam
person, you are you are learning person.
But really what I found is that to
actually get robots to work, it's robot
robotics really in the intersection of
every single engineering discipline.
And many times a problem in one area
requires a solution in a different area.
And therefore being able to have a
visibility and intuition across the
entire stack from hardware to software
to learning to data really help you to
find a good solution quickly and help
you resolve issues quickly.
Uh and that's really the people we
found. So I'm extremely fortunate to
work with I think now like
close to 70 people at Sunday Robotics.
Uh
we really focus on
doing doing our hiring and recruiting
process on people who understand who
understand multiple discipline at once.
And what I found is that there's there's
a commonality among them. It's often
about passion and curiosity. So if
someone only like interested in like
diving deep into one aspect or they just
want to follow the flow, you know, like
whatever school teach me, now I'm a
mechanical engineer, I'll keep doing the
same thing, nobody's like
the our education system is does not
provide enough guidance on how do you
actually acquire all these breadth of
knowledge. And what we found is that
people who are really really passionate
about what they're doing and really
curious about how things work, they will
naturally uh
you know, kind of diverge from what
they're doing as their main job to to to
see okay, you know, the like they'll
take apart like a clock, they'll take
apart like a robot and then they will
really understand how things work
underneath. And we found that these kind
of like a breadth of understanding is
extremely critical to get robotics to
work.
And yeah, toward the end, so if you
think you found a like-minded people,
you also you know, enjoyed this kind of
full stack moment or learn
you aspire to become
like a full stack roboticist, you want
to understand all everything,
please check out our website.
Yeah, that's it.
>> [applause]
>> Hi, thanks for the talk.
I'm pretty curious about your your
approach to locomotion
because a lot of companies like Figure
and others are going for legged
humanoids and you guys have this this
rolling base approach. But again, like
Sunday Robotics is targeting the home.
Um you know, is your is your plan to to
move forward like yeah, what's your
approach to to locomotion for
you know, houses that have multiple
floors, things like that.
Is it kind of like a perfect concept for
now or is it something that you guys are
planning on working on?
Yeah, I think this is a very good
question. Uh I would say the the way we
think about like a problem and a big
companies actually very different. Like
a big company, they need to address the
entirety market of human otherwise it's
not worth it for them. But as a startup,
it's very important for us to focus on a
small like a small subset like a niche
category of people and really satisfy
their their need. And we believe there's
enough people where there's only one
floor and and then they will they will
happily buy a robot. And so for our very
for our very first product, we'll like
you know, we're definitely going with
like the wheel-based approach. I think
that's good enough. The robot is
passively stable in any state. If you
cut power, it's not going to fall, it's
going to not going to hurt anybody. And
I think that's a really difficult aspect
to guarantee for a you know, for a
bipedal robot. So I would say you know,
eventually I think that's very something
very very interested in exploring.
But like like I think before there's a
consensus what does safety even mean for
a humanoid in the home, I will be very
cautious about that approach.
Thanks for a a great talk and a very
unique one on on the full stack today.
I had a question on on the the learning
aspect and the data aspect that you
spoke a little bit about at the end. Um
you talked about the the work that Perry
and his his team are doing in in data
labeling and data collection. Do you
feel like human demonstration
trajectories created by that team are
sufficiently scalable for the the
learning that you're trying to
do with with your robots or are you guys
also exploring some of the the recent
directions that have been seen in in
video models and world models that try
to learn from more internet scale data
as well?
Yeah, so I can't say too much about our
future research direction,
but I would say even within the
organization, how we collect data
actually changes over time quite
significantly. And then the kind of data
we collect changes significantly. Really
like everything is a variable. The only
thing constant is the people. It's it's
the same people collecting data and
people have the same need, same thing
desire and they're motivated by the same
thing. And that's why I emphasize so
much. Like once you I think you you
build in a good good intuition about how
people operate, I think it's become a
lot easier.
Um I'm a really big fan of this method
using the glove for extracting data.
Um and what I'm really interested in is
also when you said okay,
it's not just a question of software,
it's also hardware and supply chain.
How did you go about thinking okay, this
is these are enough degrees of freedom,
these are enough sensors. For example,
do you want to integrate tactile
feedback to improve the policy? How many
cameras do you have on your glove? Like
that's a system-based question. How did
you guys go about that when you designed
the glove and the manipulator itself?
Yeah, very good question. I would say
like there's a couple philosophies we
follow. Number one, like we follow like
you know, simplicity is really the name
of the game here. So like hardware is
not like software. Like every complexity
you introduce like exponentially grow up
in terms of probability of that causing
a failure. So really we we think that
having the bare minimum in terms of
complexity is key to actually ship
something that's reliable.
Um and
so in terms of like when we started
prototyping, it's really about our
engineering intuition. So the Tony and
I, we have the same we did a lot of
robotic during our PhD. We understand
roughly what kind of geometry, what kind
of degree of freedom is enough for the
task we care about
and and for what sensors we use. And
then after that, it's all about
iteration. So we have like I think for
the glove we iterated probably like 100
150 times
of like various changes versions of of
CAD. And then you print a glove, you try
it, you try on different things. It's
really you know, it's a brand new thing,
nobody has done it before. So you just
have to try a lot of things. And that's
why I think having hardware and software
and learning in the same like under the
same roof so important. It's allow you
to have a very, very tight feedback loop
on your entire system, not just from
each component.
Uh when you're getting that much data
from that many users, how do you
maintain the data quality and like
filter it? And have you ever gotten
weird data from users?
Yeah, that's a that's you know, very
common problem. Uh I would say, look,
filtering is definitely very important.
But I would say it's actually much more
important uh for people to like number
one get clearly communicated of what you
want. And to make sure our people like
what they're trying to do is aligned
with what what you're trying to do. If
everybody all they're trying to do is to
game the system, there's actually very
like there are there's a million edge
cases you wouldn't thought of. But if
you they understand that okay, I want
this to
I want I to use the data to help the
robot to work. And these are the thing
these are the aspect that a robot will
likely care about. And uh these like
these are like the impact of the data. I
think people often quickly align with
what we want to do.
Do you have time for one more question?
Or do you have to go?
>> I have time. Hi. Hey. Um what's your
relationship with data collectors? Like
do you pay them? And like beyond that,
um how does [laughter] how do you or
Perry like motivate them to collect like
more or more quality data for you? Like
how do you nudge them?
Yeah, yeah. So right now I will pay
them. Uh and then I think that's very
important you know you know getting
other people's time uh like you you have
to pay them
uh I would say. Uh I think there are uh
there are many attempts uh I think in
industry of uh just collecting data in a
in a structured way. I think those those
data are still very helpful. Uh but
often uh what you find is that the the
the distribution you want uh
from the data is not exactly the same as
the distribution in the real world.
Sometimes pretty much you you want to do
important sampling for aspects you care
about. Uh in those cases uh you to
instruct some people instruct people in
a very detailed way. And what's the
second half of the question?
How about the motivation beyond payment?
Any motivation beyond paying them?
What's the second part?
>> Yeah, I would say uh just uh
you know, there are people who is you
know, stay at home mom. There are people
who are like actually like you know,
very like old people that like they just
want to help their children for next
generation. Well, I think it's just that
uh
like just like I feel like a lot of
people like they want like they
understand that there's a wave of AI
robotics that's happening. A lot of them
really want to be part of it. But you
know, they they they don't actually have
like a like a entry for them to you
know, they're not like you guys you're
where you this nice lecture hall, you
can take classes, you can code. And then
and we can understand how to how to help
them. Like really there are many people
interested. Uh but we need to explain to
them what's the clear connection between
the work they're doing. And like what
actually how does that kind of impact
other people in the other in the world.
And then we found that helping them
build a connection to be very important.
Um
Do you have time for one last question?
Or do you need to go? Uh yeah, I have
time.
Thank you.
Um I assume that uh
changing the last uh
in the last year of your PhD changing
the university have had positive impact
to attracting more investors. And
probably it was the goal that
um you change it. And I was wondering
how was it possible if it may if I may
ask and um
um yeah
>> Oh yeah, well so so I was that's
actually quite different. So uh that's
my my my my advisor changed university,
not me changing the university. And then
she took me with her. Uh
so I mean, I think you like I think PhD
and undergrad are quite different. I
think for undergrad there are a lot of
transfer opportunities.
Uh and I would say for PhD it's a much
more about the a specific advisor you're
working with than the university. Uh so
you when you see a faculty move
you know, across the uh different uh
places, they often take their students
with them.
Thank you so much.
Yeah, cool. Uh I think we are done. Uh
let's thank again Cheng for his very
insightful talk.
>> [applause]